et alors c'est pas si vous savez mais
pokemon en fait c'est un mot anglais qui
est un peu contracté ça veut dire pocket
monsters en anglais c'est toi qu'est la
reine de hollande lui ça veut dire
monstres de poche fautivement square
alors comme date certes un petit lennar
ont eu la chance de voir pokémon de en
avant-première et voici donc les tout
premiers avis sur ce film damon 2 alors
si tu n'étais bien ce que y avait des
nouveaux pokémon la dation
j'aime bien plus catch où il se trouve
union si parce qu'ils y une vedette
c'est le premier pokémon qui a été
connue alors pokémon qu'est ce que
j'adore le puits soro bon bah soyons
concret vous avez beaucoup beaucoup aimé